so after a whole movies worth of
journeying Bilbo and the dwarves will
finally get a chance to pilfer from a
fearsome dragon in the new movie The
Hobbit desolation of Smaug Smaug might
be the first decent CG dragon ever
in the last two decades it's been an
iron rule of fantasy cinema that real
actors and computer dragons just don't
mix ever since dragon heart boy that
giant lizard with Sean Connery's voice
didn't seem fearsome he seemed
ridiculous no I would be honored to be
named after those stars right and his
flappy lip movements still haunt my
nightmares ditto with the god-awful mm
Dungeons & Dragons and rain of fire and
Eragon more like Eragon
am i right because you see that never
mind
humor our art TV shows don't fare any
better
the only reason Game of Thrones gets
away with it is because appearances by
its CG dragons only make up about 45
seconds of the show's 30 hour runtime
what makes this worse is that before
computers cinematic dragons were awesome
the trailblazing movie dragon and fritz
lang's des Nibelungen was well it was
pretty impressive for 1924 I mean I felt
for him when he got stabbed
and animatronics got much better over
the years yo sup Falkor and no cg movie
has yet matched Dragonslayer which
represents the pinnacle of stop-motion
effects before computers killed that
artform Phil Tippett's go motion for the
win
what happened it could be that some dark
necromancer placed a curse on the
fantasy genre but I prefer to blame the
American Godzilla the movie that
portrayed a thousand kaiju conventions
the sheer unconvincing nosov its central
monster clearly touched off a shock wave
of suck so why are dragons so very hard
I suspect it's because they occupy an
awkward place in the monster spectrum
they can't just be giant lizards the way
Kong is a giant gorilla they're not
dinosaurs like in Jurassic Park but they
can't be purely mythical creatures like
basilisks
rendering dragons combines the
difficulties of all free of these phyla
of movie monster dough so all you
effects gurus at weather I hope you are
using more to Canaan's faithful mousepad
which has a +10 attack bonus you need
golem you can do this I wonder if Andy
Serkis is doing mocap for smoke that
might help
I for one I'm gonna have a hard time
wrapping my head around why Smaug sounds
like Sherlock Holmes leave a comment and
let me know what you think about
Benedict Cumberland did cumberbund
cucumber Blanche